you know somebody brought this
up this idea with gpg3 that
it's uh so it's trained in a
self-supervised way on
basically internet data and
that's one of the i've seen arguments
made and they
seem to be pretty convincing that the
bottom like there is going to be
how much data there is on the internet
which is a fascinating idea that
it literally will just run out of human
generated data
to train on it's uh i know we make it to
the point where it's consumed
basically all of human knowledge or all
digitized human knowledge yeah and that
would be the bottleneck i mean
but the the interesting thing with
bottlenecks
is people often use bottlenecks as way
to argue against exponential growth
is say well there's no way you can
overcome this bottleneck but we seem to
somehow keep coming up in new ways
to like overcome whatever bottlenecks
the uh
the critics come up with just
fascinating i don't know how you
overcome the
data bottleneck but probably more
efficient training algorithms
yeah well you already mentioned that
that these training algorithms are
getting much better at using smaller
amounts of data we also are just
capturing a lot more data than we used
to especially
in china but all around us so those are
both important
you know in some applications you can
simulate the data you know video games
some of the the self-driving car systems
are you know simulating driving
and uh of course that has some risks and
weaknesses but you can also
in if you want to you know exhaust all
the different ways you could beat a
video game you could just simulate all
the options
you